Multimedia and analyzing let's just
review what what he is it's good
different color showing what is
analyzing what does it mean what's the
most succinct concise definition you
could give of analyzing what do you
think
I'll start you off okay it's the process
that does what what does it accomplish
what does it achieve I give you another
clue it takes it takes one thing and
transforms it into another is that
enough warm up for your cold 8:00 a.m.
brains what does it do
what's it take data in other words raw
unn unn I was gonna say a process but
that's not very helpful word unsorted
I'm categorized non meaningful and
meaningless almost data right a chance
over into what yes thank you okay we
work up successfully um it takes things
which don't have that much meaning to
anyway okay and and looks for meaning
looks for patterns look for trends looks
for things that are important or
significant yeah or purposeful so an
example I gave you was Donna is a bit
like if you if you ever played with Lego
when you're a little kid I'll still
close that's totally fine no shame in it
right you don't like a big box big crate
and all the pieces are in there okay and
if you just poured that out and there's
no rhyme or reason to it at all that'd
be Donna right but transforming into
something meaningful might mean I'm
organizing it by color sorting it in
that way right
or maybe sorting it by size or shape or
you know you know there's some special
pieces or like people versus blocks
versus you can do it any way you'd like
okay something meaningless into
something meaningful now do you think
about multimedia and its relation to
this process what do I mean what do we
mean on there
two things number one multimedia can be
what do you make here it can be the
information right so for instance we're
talking about Lego just now I could say
look don't just put into those piles and
organize it in that way or categorize it
in that way but let's do a count how
many red pieces are there how many
yellow pieces are there and that kind of
thing right and then we could draw like
a chart or a pie yeah a pie chart
something like that okay so multimedia
can be the analysis it can be the
information you produce which is
meaningful based on some raw data
okay so multimedia can be the analysis
it can be the information that you okay
but conversely if you looking at the
other way around
okay multimedia might not be what you
end with multimedia can be what you
start with okay
multimedia can be that data that you're
actually looking at finding patterns
searching for I'm trying to get some
understanding and purpose out of it
right so multimedia can be the thing
okay so let's think about this for a
second uh you guys have studied
multimedia for a time now right so you
know there's heaps of data associated
with the multimedia itself okay so
example you take a picture you take a
picture okay what kind of data is bound
up in that picture let's start with the
obvious stuff what kind of data is in
the picture what makes up the picture
say we're stored as a bitmap what's the
data in there Ricky what would you say
colors yeah thank you
you've got millions of colors that make
up your picture okay that's what the
picture is let's be a little more
specific here right
not just colors right but you can save
stuff like say be depth you could say
things like resolution how many pixels
you actually have okay good that's a
start that's what a picture is
consisting of okay but most of you most
of the picture you taken recently
probably especially if you took them on
say iPhone include a lot more data than
this it's not just the colors that
they're some of this extra data that's
hidden in what other data is then yeah
thank you okay so same time so there's
quite a logical data stored in there
alongside the colors and all that kind
of thing so you can order them by you
can water them by when they were taken
easy all right
what was balloons before with you with
your photo right yeah Ricky Geronimo
yeah thank you sir I let's let's go back
a step so the data that's bound up in
this as well which you don't usually see
unless you're looking for it is usually
GPS data it's location data so do these
completely different categories of data
all wound up in the picture
and this is called geo-tagging right gia
as in geographical okay I don't know how
many of you are sort of into photography
and that kind of thing
but if you don't take your picture with
a phone if you take it with like a real
camera like you know a heavy one when
you're gonna hold it two hands black so
huge lens on it okay there's even more
data on there there's a whole data type
called exif data type which is
associated with all the little lead
egrets nitty-gritty bit server
photographic details that are bound up
in a picture for instance things like
aperture which is how wide the camera
lens is open when it's absorbing light
things I'd say shutter speed which is
how long the camera is absorbing life
right
other things like ISO settings which is
about light sensitivity and I could go
on and on and on okay so all of these
pieces of information even the model of
the camera that you took it on they're
all stored in the photo okay and you can
see all of these things can be analyzed
right so this is yeah sorry this one
this is Multimedia being the theme being
analyzed